we have seen that under some conditions
the binomial PMF is well approximated by
a Poisson PMF but we have also seen the
central limit theorem that tells us that
the binomial PMF can be approximated
using a normal random variable can we
reconcile these two facts let us look
into the situation in some more detail
consider a Poisson process that has rate
equal to 1 and consider that Poisson
process running over the unit time
interval we take the unit interval and
we split it into many small sub
intervals where each sub interval has a
length of 1 over N and let X I be the
number of arrivals that we get during
the i's interval X I is a Poisson random
variable and the mean of that random
variable or the parameter of that random
variable is just the duration of the
time interval since the rate is 1 so
it's a Poisson random variable with
parameter 1 over N now let us look at
the total number of arrivals the total
number of arrivals is the sum of how
many arrivals we had during each one of
these intervals and we know the
distribution of s s is a Poisson random
variable with parameter equal to 1 now
here what we have is a sum of random
variables that are independent and
identically distributed they are
identically distributed because all of
these intervals have the same length and
they're independent because in the
Poisson process what happens in
different intervals are independent
events so we are in a situation where we
could apply the central limit theorem we
have a sum of many independent
identically distributed random variables
and by letting n go to infinity the
central limit theorem appears to tell us
that s is going to be normal
now how can we reconcile these two facts
we know that the Poisson distribution is
not the same as a normal distribution
what is the cut
well the cut is the following the
central limit theorem applies to a
situation where we fix a certain
probability distribution the
distribution of the x i's and the tells
us that as we add more and more of these
X is asymptotically we obtain a
distribution that's well approximated by
a normal on the other hand what we have
here is actually different the x i's do
not have a fixed distribution but rather
the distribution of x i depends on n
that is if we change n so that we're
adding more random variables we are
adding more random variables that are
now coming from a different distribution
and this is not a situation to which the
central limit theorem applies and
therefore this conclusion here is not
justified and so there is no
contradiction between the two types of
approximations to summarize the
situation is as follows
consider a binomial random variable with
some parameters N and P now let P be
fixed and let n go to infinity in that
case the binomial random variable can be
thought of as the sum of n Bernoulli
random variables and those Bernoulli
random variables have a parameter P
which is fixed so we're dealing with the
sum of iid random variables from a fixed
distribution and this is the situation
where the central limit theorem applies
and we have a normal approximation on
the other hand if we take the product n
times P which is the expected value of
this binomial to stay constant but we
let n
to infinity and at the same time left P
go to zero then in this regime in the
limit this random variable will be well
approximated by a Poisson random
variable so we have two different
approximations both of them are valid
but they're valid in different regimes
now although they are different there is
actually an interesting case in which
the two will not really differ and this
is the following consider a Poisson
random variable with parameter N and
we're interested in the limit as n goes
to infinity we can think of this random
variable as the number of arrivals
during an interval of length and in a
Poisson process with arrival rate equal
to 1 now let us take this interval and
split it into n intervals each of which
has a length of 1 and let us call X I
the number of arrivals in the i's
interval our Poisson random variable is
going to be of course equal to the sum
of the number of arrivals during each
one of the intervals each one of these
random variables is Poisson with
parameter equal to 1 and these random
variables are actually iid now what's
happening in this case is that even when
we increase n because we're using
constant length intervals the
distribution of the x i's doesn't change
so this is a situation in which we are
going to get approximately a normal
random variable as n goes to infinity so
what we see is that the poisson random
variable but with a very large parameter
starts to approach the normal
distribution and this in particular
would tell us that these two
approximations that we have in some
regime they would start to agree
now all this discussion here has been
asymptotic we talked about P going to 0
and going to infinity but in any real
situation
you will be given actual numbers and you
cannot really tell is this number close
to zero or is it not here we need some
rules of thumb or maybe some experience
let us look at some examples in this
case n times P is equal to 1 so the
number of arrivals or the values of the
binomial random variable will take
values 0 1 2 3 but with high probability
not a lot more than that so the binomial
random variable is really a discrete
random variable there's no way to
approximate it with a normal on the
other hand P is very small so a Poisson
approximation would be very reasonable
in this situation on the other hand if P
is equal to one-third then definitely
one-third is not a small number a
Poisson approximation would not apply
but n is pretty big so that a normal
approximation would be appropriate and
finally in this case we would obtain a
Poisson approximation with parameter a
hundred because n times P is a hundred
but the Poisson random variable with
parameter 100 is also well approximated
by a normal or to think about it
differently we start with a Bernoulli
distribution that's very skewed only
probability of success is just 100 and
this makes it difficult for the central
limit theorem to apply when you start
with a very asymmetric distribution on
the other hand because we're adding so
many of them the central limit theorem
actually does take hold and so this is
an example where both approximations
will be valid so finally to conclude we
have two different approximations they
are valid in different regimes and in
practice you need to do some thinking
before deciding to choose one verse
the other approximation